là je vois une réforme qui ne cherchent
pas dans ce qui est annoncé à renforcer
l'efficacité du travail de ce moment
c'est en tout cas parce que les voitures
l'exécutif n'a pas de dévoiler oui mais
on voit bien ce qui est avancé c'est il
faut faire plus efficacement la loi mais
moi je constate comme parlementaire que
très souvent la loi est mal faite parce
que l'exécutif qu'à lille
la quasi-totalité de l'initiative
parlementaire nous vous nous donne des
lois qui ou sans étude d'impact réel
il n'y a pas le suivi derrière et c'est
souvent l'exécutif qui la fit selman et
nous consacrons nous au sénat en
particulier nous sommes attachés à un
travail de fond
très souvent c'est nous qui corrige les
imperfections de la loi donc par exemple
le droit d'amendement qui est menacée on
en parlera chaque pour chaque
parlementaire
je vais vous dire on peut s'opposer
surtout quand on est à l'opposition mais
la réalité c'est que quand on fait un
amendement me propose
on va les finir sur ce droit
d'amendement oui on va écouter andré
chassaigne mais sur une des lignes
rouges de gérard marché par exemple le
non cumul des mandats dont le temps
l'exécutif veut limiter ce cumul des
mandats 3 est ce que ça c'est un point
de blocage pour vous aussi au pas du
tout non c'est pas ça le point de
blocage
d'autant que le parti socialiste a fait
cette proposition ait fait cette
proposition dans depuis un certain temps
trois bombes à ça va c'est bien vous
n'êtes pas contre on n'est pas contre on
est même pour avant même que c était
proposée par ou en marche ou par le
présent d'arrêt mais la chanteuse
l'exécutif à exclure les mêmes 2002
moins 3500 victoire oui ça c'est bien
aussi mais je sais c'est pas là le sujet
le sujet fondamental c est ce que l'on
renforce le parlement où est ce que l'on
renforce le pouvoir de l'exécutif
or aujourd'hui il y a y compris dans la
méthode moi j'aime regarder ce qui est
fait concrètement ordonnant sur le code
du travail
ordonnance sur la loi ferroviaire vote
bloqué sur les retraites des
agriculteurs
la tendance de ce pouvoir de ce
gouvernement est de 20 degrés duels
autoritarisme et au pouvoir bâtir mais
est ce que cette révision
constitutionnel renforce les pouvoirs du
parlement comme vous le demander où est
ce qu'à nourrir l'antiparlementarisme
pour moi le nourris dont tu
parlementarisme c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure le sait alimenter le fait
que le parlement est là pour bavarder
alors qu'il faut être efficace c'est
réduire le nombre de parlementaires par
exemple bien entendu ce lundi aux
français ils sont trop bon c'est vrai
que ils vivent une efficacité de
l'action publique qu'ils disent ils sont
trop pour peu de résultats mais la
réalité c'est que si on pose la question
aux français ce que vous voulez des
parlementaires alors j'y suis éloigné de
vous si en a moins ils seront plus
éloignés dans le territoire de chaque
citoyen ça sera des circonscriptions
plus large lui c'est donc ce que je
pense je finis là dessus c'est que il
faut arrêter de d'aller dans le sens du
populisme parce que ceux qui gouvernent
vont recevoir le retour de bâton très
fort parce que l'on sait que c'est pas
seulement en france mais dans toute
l'europe
c'est une tendance qu'il faut combattre